der neue bundestag ist im prinzip wie
der alte bundestag nur mit neuen jungen
leuten ach ist das aufregend wie fühlt
sich das so an im bundestag es war
aufregend also ich finde dieses gebäude
riesig groß und krass und fremd wenn er
das thema das er gesagt hätte hätte ich
glaube die person führer halb verrückt
erklärt für die jüngste abgeordnete
haben wir sogar eine schultüte
mitgebracht mit mega krassen geschenken
wie zum beispiel das buch von annalena
baerbock
ach so ja wir haben das genommen was sie
selbst geschrieben hat
ich habe genau das hat ehrlich wir sind
sie nicht selbst gesteht dass auch nicht
es ist tatsächlich noch was drin man sie
noch mal nachgucken
sehen sie es da ist drin kein tempolimit
eine aufrechnung der schuldenbremse und
keine steuererhöhungen
was liegt denn hier jetzt schon so an
papierkram rum sind es schon sicher sein
dass ihn die ein lobby post tatsächlich
schon so ich hab schon im wahlkampf
lobby post bekommen irgendwie
mineralölunternehmens zum beispiel die
sich als erstes gemeldet haben
zeitarbeitsfirmen und das erste was ist
in meinem pass von hat sich im bundestag
ankam war von einem waffenlager das ist
richtig ich kenne mich ja schon ein
bisschen aus dem bundestag deswegen
wollte ich ihnen als neuer abgeordneter
den wichtigsten ort hier im gebäude
zeigen
der geldautomat und
falls mal nichts mehr rauskommt kleiner
tipp von mir lässt man sich einfach vom
lobbyisten zum mittagessen einladen aber
ist nicht meine diät genau so hoch dass
ich mich nicht bestechen das müssen sie
die besten abgeordneten die kriegen
beides zusammen verbunden die besten
verkehr ja was man so gut findet
und dann ist es endlich soweit
konstituierende sitzung im bundestag
junge und frische abgeordnete strömen
ins parlament viele neue abgeordnete
stehen für zukunft hallo herr merken
hallo sie tipps alles was muss ich
beachten ja auf jeden fall also hier
schwimmt man mit dem strom also auch
also in der sache begründete kritik ganz
sparsam wenn überhaupt hat in den ersten
ein erster tipp ist informiert dich über
die frage wo es was zu essen gibt nichts
ist so schlimm wie am ende einer
sitzungswoche festzustellen das waren
zwei kilo abgenommen hat weil man nie
zum richtigen zeitpunkt die kantine
gefunden hat ob er aber kamen sie den
tipp an junge abgeordnete und man sollte
sich nicht zur mittagszeit in die
schlange stellen dann kriegt man
sicherlich nicht zu essen tipps für die
jungen abgeordneten immer dafür sorgen
dass man was zu essen kriegt man weiß
nie es
ist scheinbar das wichtigste das ist
wirklich wahr es ist so eine hektik in
diesem betrieb dass man die chance wenn
man was zu essen greifen kann auf jeden
fall auch ergreifen so einfach
zuschlagen zu schlagen voll reinhauen ja
wir wollen nicht nur mit den jüngsten
bundestagsabgeordneten sprechen sondern
auch mit einem der ältesten schön dass
die zeit wird er ist freut mich ihr habt
die ganze sommerpause gebraucht für
diesen tollen gag oder also sie glauben
in zwei drei monaten ist sie immer noch
ein mensch mit idealen jungen für die
sozialdemokratie und nicht auf olaf
scholz linie also erst mal ich kenne
niemanden und ist muss zuschauen wie das
geht ich kenne niemanden der mehr ideale
hat olaf solak chance olaf scholz ist
quasi das sind ideale auf beinen
kann hier merkt also carlos für den
humor in der heute show verantwortlich
selbst bringt
also die ideale kann man haben das ist
durchaus gar nicht das problem man darf
sie nicht der erste tag ist vorüber ich
hoffe ich konnte ihnen beiden ein
bisschen was beibringen
auf jeden fall sehr gut ironie
beherrschen die beiden schon mal und
damit von der zukunft des parlaments
zurück zum alten weißen mann im studio
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbol ihr bei uns im neuen studio
gefunden illuminati freimaurer
staatsführung ist alles dabei dann
wollen wir denn die eigentlichen
strippenzieher bekannt geben
dass so viele abonnenten auf youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten